there was a woman
who went viral yesterday
she's an Arizona teacher explaining why
parents should have no right to control
the books that are on the curricula that
their kids are being taught this
involves a bill called SB 1700 would
require the Arizona Department of
Education to maintain a list of books
that public educational institutions may
not use or make available to students
now before people start whining about
book bands and book burning and we need
to allow all books you know that that
isn't true first of all the most
important book in our whole civilization
is currently banned in schools you're
not allowed to teach the Bible in
schools which is absurd
but there are plenty of books that are
banned in schools or that have been
banned that should be banned pornography
you're not allowed to have a huge porn
collection in schools well at least you
weren't until recently now actually woke
teachers are smuggling in specifically
gay porn so this bill says you're not
allowed to have lewd or sexual books
books that promote gender fluidity or
gender pronouns or groom children or
normalize pedophilia and this bill
I'm just quoting from the text of the
bill by the way grants parents the right
to request removal of the school
district or Charter School library or
classroom materials extends public
review periods for Library materials and
District textbooks and removes
exceptions from District curriculum
approval and school library access
requirements really pretty basic stuff
parents have the right to not have their
kids exposed to weird creepy porn and
pedo stuff in the schools in the public
schools that they're funding seems
pretty normal right one teacher says
absolutely not parents have no right to
do this because some parents don't even
have a master's degree
I have a master's degree because when I
got certified I was told I had to have a
master's degree to be an Arizona
certified teacher
we all have advanced degrees what do the
parents have are we vetting the
backgrounds of our parents are we
allowing the parents to choose the
curriculum and the books that our
children are going to read I think that
it's a mistake I'm just speaking from
the heart
the one line that I love is we must
remember that the purpose of public
education is not to teach only what
parents want their children to be taught
it is to teach them what Society needs
them to be taught
we have master's degrees what do these
parents have right reason and proper
perception and a good formation and a
rational will and love for their
children
but they don't even have a master's
degree
I
do not wish to demean anybody's
educational accomplishments or
credentials or whatever
these degrees mean nothing
they mean nothing
a master's degree means nothing
a bachelor's degree now means nothing
a PhD still
in many disciplines still means
something I guess but in some
disciplines actually not that much it
there are plenty of very smart good
normal people with master's degrees some
listen some of my best friends have
master's degrees okay but it doesn't
mean anything
and the fact that this woman
got her Master's Degree because she
needed that to get this job as a teacher
working to Peddle this crazy left-wing
agenda means that it means even less
than it ever did
what are we really talking about here
once you get past all the credentialism
and all the bureaucracy and all the
layers that the state has established to
mold your children's Minds
the question is hey
what should your kids learn
and if the lady with the Master's Degree
says your kids should be taught gay porn
in the fifth grade
then that does not speak very highly of
the credential but this is what they say
they say you don't if you don't have the
special credential
then you don't get to have a say about
how your kids are raised how your
government is conducted what your
immigration policy is what the foreign
policy is
nothing
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it become a member
and use code Knowles can a wlas a
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]